that's why I get in trouble
I know
it's like don't don't please don't don't
get canceled everybody Dwayne Johnson
here and finally I'm going to find out
what the lad Bible audience thinks of me
let's get this show on the road
which film would you love Dwayne to
remake yeah okay so he's given some
options okay The Flintstones The
Terminator Twilight Saga Die Hard Rocky
oh man what would you wanna do
I would have to go with Twilight Saga
okay yeah
classic film because they're vampires
right that's the thing yeah I just want
to go around just sucking blood out
okay The Flintstones yes perfect
no but I'll give it a shot I don't know
that's funny though
okay what is Dwayne Johnson's best
feature okay what do you think it is oh
you want me without pressing it yeah my
best feature is where I get in trouble
I know
it's like don't don't please don't don't
get canceled
um I think probably maybe my smile okay
let's go for it here we go smile a
intelligence right eyebrow there you go
humor and muscles what do you think they
said I'm gonna I'm gonna go with two I'm
gonna go with
um
I'm gonna go with humor and intelligence
boom hey humor but look at intelligence
out of these DC heroes who does Dwayne
think would win in the fight okay here
we go
um Gal Gadot Wonder Woman okay
Dwayne Johnson's Black Adam
Henry Cavill Superman
Robert Patton's patinson's Batman that's
a tough one this is where you go uh are
you but you know what Gal Gadot is bad
Wonder Woman I will start with Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman is bad off bad isn't
good
uh Robert Pattinson's Batman I just saw
that really good Batman's tough
um the most powerful force in the entire
universe is Superman what about yourself
I know
here we go Dwayne Johnson's Black Adam
Black Adam
Black Adam will bring the Thunder okay
you would have to yeah he was the number
one
all right that's what I think okay yes
all right here we go I have a feeling
they're gonna say Superman
got it perfect it is close look at that
34-36 yeah yeah very very close what's
cool about that that tells me the lab
Bible uh audience they know they're
superheroes and they know that Black
Adam has all the superpowers of Superman
and it's it's close it's a close race
he's right there Toe to Toe okay uh but
there is no one like Superman all right
do you want to see Dwayne as president
of the United States of America uh lad
Bible audience I'm gonna say
unequivocally they're gonna say yes
there we go it's looking good that's
good I know you said recently that you
own but you never mind uh
uh I you never know you never know but I
appreciate the lad Bibles yeah I
appreciate it I appreciate the belief
thank you guys if Dwayne wasn't an actor
which other job do you think he would do
knowing the lad Bible audience like I
know the lad Bible audience well I would
say um
probably a chemical engineer
why is everyone snickering guys okay
hold on a great coach a great sports
coach
and a gynecologist
here we go
CIA agent yeah okay because he studied
that is very true by the way
bouncer
I know what a bouncer is what
do you know what it is yes I know what
it bounds
you know at the end of the night they're
like hey get back out
um yeah I don't know if I was I was a
bouncer a few times my day's in Tampa
number one at the strip clubs um
personal trainer yeah yeah so that could
kind of work yeah I was a personal
trainer at one time
um you like personal training if that's
something
um I did not like it no and I was coming
out of college and um part of the gym
memberships for the gym that I used to
work at UH you got two workouts with a
personal trainer yeah I was not a
certified personal trainer but they were
like you could train them anyway I'm
like all right yeah come on I'll train
you I did not like it that much because
I found that uh everyone who uh I
started to personally train just um just
talked all the time and I'm like this is
not no it's not not it's not what we're
trying to do here okay so you know that
one person actually did say porn star I
just had to say it porn star yeah
all right because that's my people bad
Bible they know they know
which of these film series would you
most like to see Dwayne in
James Bond you know my grandfather was
in You Only Live Twice
he was he was a bad guy and you only
lived twice he had this amazing fight
scene with Sean Connery okay Harry
Potter yeah I could see that me and
Harry yeah
yeah I could be a sorcerer
teaching the ropes yeah show him porn
I'm just bringing the porn joke back
that's what it is guys all right Star
Wars I love Star Wars one of my all-time
favorites
Lord of the Rings
oh got it I would easily say James Bond
or Star Wars
see yes
hey James Bond overwhelming response
it's very cool
um a bond villain no what myself was
James Bond okay
the villain
an American bug it can happen it can
happen right it's like Henry Cavill
playing Superman is that yeah I do like
the idea of my boy uh Idris Elba being
right I like that idea a lot yeah so I'm
an advocate for that yeah for him as
Bond yeah Adrian sponge the campaign
here we go okay
uh what is Dwayne's best movie
um lab Bible audience are either going
to say uh Jumanji or Black Adam
or Hobson show
The Scorpion King nice Moana nice
Jumanji I got it what can I say except
you're welcome there you go there you go
what do you think uh Duane's ultimate
workout song is oh this is good
but what is your workouts at the moment
at the moment it's the Black Adam theme
okay it's
it's a badass yes it's very intense uh
that face off and
um
I'm so sexy you know that's something
I'm Too Sexy yeah there you go okay
face off step nine there you go uh as it
was Harry Styles about damn time lizzo I
like that I had a Tiger It's one of my
Classics yeah okay let's see what they
said very cool I had the tiger you know
what I love it close with face off as
well close with face off I do rock eye
the tiger a lot by the way what TV show
do you most want to see Dwayne on oh
that's good it's this is more like
reality shows oh reality show got it uh
the Great British cook-off how do what
is it Great British Bake Off all my
British friends tell me to watch that
show all right here we go Dancing with
the Stars
you guys aren't ready for me on Dancing
With the Stars
the great yeah but it's big off I got
that right number two very cool and
number one Ninja Warrior yeah let me
tell you something
I really would
he'd be amazing in it all right well I'd
be something thank you
everybody
let's do one more one more last one
last one okay uh what would Dwayne
Johnson most like to play who uh with
Dwayne Johnson most like to play him in
a biopic
I would say
I mean who I don't I don't know we had
this all the time like Kevin Hart okay
let's see see yes all right all right
there we go
Jason Momoa Dwayne Johnson of course I
got to play myself that's great guys
thank you that was a lot of fun thank
you thank you very much just to let you
know that one person did say naked
attraction really yeah well that's
obviously my biggest fan what is naked
attraction oh it's that show you dirty